[Music]
this was just for you Merch this next
one bro this next one was specifically a
story that was honestly done just for
you okay
go with this [ __ ] guy again this crew
hey Virgie can you read the title of it
for March
of the video please yeah hold on hold on
where where I gotta go open upward yeah
yeah Michael Strahan's journey to see
polar bears amid climate crisis
oh
what
I don't want to be around just for you
[Laughter]
[Music]
I don't want to be around anymore
what does that do for the common good
I love this local show this has been the
best I love these shows God damn it
that's like the only time that line was
finally perfect
I get to go meet polar bears
now he is way up North he's on an
important message
tundra in Churchill Manitoba Canada yes
no Pros
do you understand Stephanopoulos paid
out of his own pocket to get a weak
break
do you understand he was hilarious yeah
he was like look we sent him somewhere
in a North Pole or some [ __ ] and they
took him literally
changed
yet I want to see if we can find where
they make the toys oh
awful cold before
you know what George you say that like
you have concern but then I hear all the
lights
good morning good morning to all of you
and it is absolutely freezing out here
the wind is whipping the snow is coming
from every direction like that that rain
how do you think this guy seriously I'm
not scared of the polar bears because I
brought plenty of cans of Coca-Cola and
if I recall correctly I believe that
they very much enjoy that stuff I want
to point out that Mercer's Michael
Strahan impression is more racist than
my joke I just want to make sure that
everybody knows
why it's just a lispy [ __ ]
it's nothing racial about it
everywhere I'm tearing up but cold aside
this is truly breathtaking I mean really
the dealership is getting so much worse
it's cold did he say no he did say
breathtaking right yeah oh is he doing
another is he doing another [ __ ]
transpiece
knees are sideways everywhere I'm
tearing up but cold aside this is truly
breathtaking yeah you heard that right
if you heard that right we're gonna be
transitioning polar bears
thank you
I mean really the beautiful place to see
in person and the animals that call
Churchill Manitoba home well they are
just incredible and we're here to see
one animal in particular the Magnificent
polar bear Churchill Manitoba is one of
the southernmost homes he walks up he's
like holy [ __ ] or pull it but like holy
[ __ ] a black guy
what are they doing here the old first
time a polar bear is intimidated yeah
of the polar bear and I spent yesterday
on one of these buggies behind me with
difficult polar versus like there goes
the neighborhood oh the tundra buggy and
we drove to where the the Bears live we
got as close as possible to them in
their natural habitat while keeping a
safe distance which is very important we
learned so much about how these
beautiful creatures live and um eat and
what they eat and how they're home okay
so yeah we already know all this they're
not Beautiful Creatures they're actually
terrifying and very violent creatures
and to answer your question they eat
everything even sometimes their own Cubs
yeah absolutely they do
thread from climate change it must have
been amazing to see a Polar Polar Bears
were another one of those like save the
rainforest [ __ ] climate change things
because like it ended up blowing up in
their face now polar bears are so far
down south that they're mating with
grizzly bears and making hybrid [ __ ]
terrorists right now we have mulatto but
then we have mulatto Bears Super
exciting that's what we needed mulatto
bears
so now these [ __ ] polar bears are
miscegenating and now they they don't
live in either bare world
um I want you to look at this for a
second
he's a child look look at what the
little binoculars he's a child he looks
like he's looking through one of those
old viewfinders
and now I'm at the pyramids
where's your Michael Strahan [ __ ]
murders me every single day God damn it
I'm climbing it must have been amazing
to see a polar bear up close amazing
[ __ ] Church stuff and I was like why
don't you stay for another week
maybe maybe stay for another week or
something
just once we start with
two Cubs okay the porridge and one of
the points just was too hot and one of
the POI just was too cold
talks like a little kid
but the middle of the mama bear it's
like a little kid coming back from the
zoo and then we saw the mama bear and
her mama bear was like oh so she was so
sweet big fat mama bear but the baby
bear's bed was just right
and the the Cubs I asked the question
how long are the Cubs with their mom
they stay with Mom for two or three
years before mama bear said and that's
longer than my dad stayed
out
right here I'm going back to being empty
nectar and you're on your own
okay you're learning a lot you're seeing
a lot we know you're cold you're having
a good time like a child they do oh my
God you're good call they are Georgetown
monopolis of course but even this of
course even this guy is treating like a
child they're all treating him like a
child
he told us about your Tundra buggy there
but it in all seriousness here though
you're here for a reason and to show why
this population of polar bears is so
important
I'm here for a real reason because I got
bear got hit like I got hit but he ain't
[ __ ] breathing okay oh I think that
that's well you know what TJ these guys
they are the first population of polar
bears whose declined in numbers
researchers were able to directly link
to climate change and sadly they'll be
one of the first Advantage if the Earth
keeps warming at the rate that is
currently warming right now and Michael
reporting on polar bears I've been a
cactovic Alaska
I know where you're going like this just
Optics wise isn't the best you're going
there where it's clearly still a frozen
tundra and then you say things like this
is the first group of polar bears who've
reduced to population in history anyway
okay so a bad thing happened it has it
consistently and continued to happen
like all the and then we had some
researchers that linked it to climate
change oh it all sounds vague I guess
yeah sure you're just tax me more now
here's the thing hear me out Michael
strike right hand
Reading Rainbow
he becomes a new Reading Rainbow Guy
think about it call it like [ __ ]
rainbow and he's just [ __ ] read books
poorly by putting his finger under the
words I was just gonna say it would be
so funny because his fingers
rainbow
DTE my brain is frozen in the sky
is [ __ ] trying to hold a book and
he's got all this really bad shakes from
the [ __ ] CD safety being a big
concern they always said it's not the
polar bear used another note for Optics
maybe if you were talking about the
decline in population of polar bears you
shouldn't have went to a business that
literally makes their bones selling
tours polar bears oh you're right Paul
Virgie good [ __ ] call bro what a good
point
holy [ __ ]
oh my God you're right Jesus [ __ ]
Christ working I didn't even think of
that you're not really selling your
point when this is thriving polar bear
tourism business
clearly they were doing well and how's
businesses you're booming actually yeah
we fill this entire bus sometimes the
problem is we have too many bears
there's so many polar bears
pactovic Alaska and I remember lean in
me is such an [ __ ] did you see what
Lena me made in the local chat hold on
what hold on I'll put it up forever I'll
put up for everybody so everyone go see
it foreign
[Laughter]
Good Morning America I don't know why
this is a thing because God is good he's
right keeps us with things and sponges
right Merc sometimes God does give with
both hands foreign
[Laughter]
hear me out Herschel needs a walker I'm
excited
big concerned they always said it's not
the polar bear you see it's the one you
don't no ma'am that is not the saying um
when you're in a bad neighborhood it's
not polar bear unless it's cold for
something else
um
so I know you have special guards with
you
yeah to protect us from all the bears
that are disappearing and are endangered
I have a team of security guards to
protect me from all these bears that we
just said are gonna all disappear
[ __ ] machine guns
[ __ ] black rock soldiers like we're
just [ __ ] private former military
people to protect what would happen if
the bear tried to attack you oh we would
murder them with guns we would shoot the
endangered polar bear with guns maybe
you should be leaving the polar bears
alone maybe you shouldn't be up there
all up in their habitat we're looking
them if they come at you with a [ __ ]
with a monster truck yeah we can't
understand why uh the population of Iraq
is shrinking uh we have been here for
three months now trying to help these
endangered people but
countless people that are dying call
that re call that Riri rainbow Lord
Pepsi called it donated yeah
well they are Amy you're exactly right
because they are extremely hard to see
even when it's clear out
which is maybe why we're just saying it
like they're endangered they don't exist
no more what if maybe it's just because
it's snowy out you know it's like can't
see the best it's like a reverse thing
they told me we have to tell the Bears
to smile
because they were their first
translucent so they just kind of blend
in but when it's like this so it's your
chance sir again going back to this
endangered population that perhaps you
might be miscounting them because
they're so hard to see go up there yeah
I mean good point I'm sure if you sent
me up there count polar bears I probably
miss a couple
oh [ __ ] you can barely see right in
front of you and you can barely see nice
nice one dude nice bro that was good
that was good that was good huh
very careful on the ground here and this
far out in the tundra today's Show's
been off the [ __ ] rails it's been off
the rails the entire show we have two
two her guards with
okay come on man now he's just [ __ ]
with us
[Applause]
yeah man today's been so weird I can't
to what
the only thing I thought those were the
bouncers outside of a gay club
dude the only thing that would make this
better is if this video ended with like
a bear approaching them and them having
to kill it live on the air to totally
just destroy their point about climate
change and how we're ruining the spirit
lives
[Laughter]
we just watched you murder two polar
bears live on television and like you
didn't even need to be there in the
first place hey quick quick hey quick
question new locals fans do you like our
show what do you say virtue make sure
you kill the babies too so that they
don't grow up to be vengeful spiteful
babies
that's what they don't tell you you
gotta kill the attack by that of the bed
that they come and get you I mean Christ
couldn't you just go to the new Bills
stadium and review their new chili
cheese dog or something oh [ __ ]
this far out
by the way I asked the locals if they
like they like to show them the kids
keep James now replied with barely let
me spell it like a bear
you started this ooh bear no stranded
okay fair enough it does and I'm gonna
ask one of them to join me Chiron come
on in here oh okay that wasn't weird and
um you know what you think of these
folks like the polar bear security
Detail no you think of them I don't even
know these people who [ __ ] existed
until two minutes ago so there's so many
bears you need a polar bear security
how much did this stupid fluff piece
cost how many beers
Bears guards this is the
system I've ever seen
[Music]
remember when they would just go to the
local zoo and be like hey check out
these Tigers they're gonna have babies
soon
you're back to your [ __ ] studio in an
hour Bing Bong bear
God I hope we have a [ __ ] new series
of Michael Strahan and precarious
situations bro anything please for the
love of God have him go like this
volcano which is expected to erupt
anytime in the next 25 years he's
wearing the heat suit the big silver
suit
I want Michael Strahan almost getting
killed dozens of times but always
surviving completely unscathed like you
know and just coming back every episode
okay so we're here live uh at the site
of where we we've seen some shocks in
the ground and they're expecting an
earthquake
and it's just Stephanopoulos sending him
to constantly get killed and he keeps
surviving without a scratch-off oh my
God he Mr Magoo's his way out of
everything that's perfect and he's such
a good sport he never really he's so
dumb he never really picks up on the
fact yeah I'm trying to kill him he just
starts being like not they're exciting
what about next huh I'm here in the
middle of Africa where Rwanda and
another Nation have just broken out in a
massive Child Soldier War
why are you doing this to Mike he
doesn't seem like a bad guy I just don't
like him I'm a demilitarized zone of
North and South Korea
great job Michael definitely let us know
how it's going on over there and then he
comes back and straight hand Spitz he's
like what happened they actually made me
the king wait what
Kim Jong-un made me honor every Senator
and he handed me this really nice award
and then he took me to I you know I
didn't realize they got like a copycat
version of McDonald's there Castle you
got a whole McDonald's in there
and then he just he sent me home in a
private jet ah [ __ ] God damn it I'm
never gonna kill this guy this would be
I would watch that show he just keeps
coming back and he's it's always works
out for him and Stephanopoulos is just
[ __ ] living every day of his life
Stephanopoulos finds out that there's a
new 911 being planned and he actually
books a flight for Herschel Walker on
one of the planes and then all of a
sudden they're like wait we got breaking
news we need to go to Herschel Walker
Michael Strahan live what's up and he's
like hi uh yes I'm here live on an
airplane where I have just subdued three
terrorists
with my football strength and uh now I
just figured I'd be the best reporter on
the scene I will now be uh uh I'm gonna
go land the plane myself and uh I would
probably tell you to get a crew out
there so we can have a big parade
oh George they also told me I'm winning
the bullet supplies for this
and actually the Congressional Medal of
Freedom well really this has been really
great George Stephanopoulos is like look
man I just made this guy the Black
Forest guy
which is totally backfired
he's on foot the other one he's in a car
nearby and we're not allowed on the
ground without these guys with us okay
so their job is to watch out for people
are dying at you sing with my football
strength
[Laughter]
okay
what he walked on all awkward like he's
he's facing the camera the whole time
yeah
it's because he's got his gun on his
back oh he does oh my God they have
what did I just say earlier I said the
same thing you have a security detail
there
so you can go in the endangered bear
habitat so if the Bears bother you and
their habitat you shoot him
it doesn't no I know you said but I
didn't notice I thought it would be a
handgun I think it was a
that's [ __ ] probably 308
you know that's polar bear guns that's
not even a metaphor that's specifically
what it's foreign
approaches he's looking around right now
making sure we're good these guys are
going to get everyone off the ground as
quickly as possible to keep us all safe
and they also have bear deterrence like
bear spray which you can think of it
bear guns and bear bullets I can assure
you right now if I ever saw a polar bear
and it came within 10 feet of me ain't
no [ __ ] bear mace or bear spray
coming out it's whatever rifle I have it
was very powerful ammunition yeah and
I'm mad Peppers those things are [ __ ]
did you ever see some of the videos
where they set up like these really
amazing cameras and then leave
they just [ __ ] videotaped them and
then [ __ ] they get these polar bears
that are like walking around the camera
eating [ __ ] and you're like you see how
[ __ ] scary they are [ __ ] that pistol
which makes a loud noise to scare the
bears away well I'm glad that's okay
good to rely on that and Michael was
totally lying in this story he's saying
oh yeah we got the mates and we got the
Lao bang guns just to scare them and
it's like no you also have that that
thing on your sling on your back I'm
going to kill any bears I have a
question and something I've probably
never even thought of how mature
Stephanopoulos is always leaning
it is weird right
you know what that is a good point he's
been leaning since the 2000s do you
think that's just his thing
or maybe it's just because he has a lot
of like don't get me wrong don't get me
wrong like sometimes maybe sometimes
you're probably right sometimes
sometimes I'll lean like I'll do one of
these we all do that but like every
single time you see him he's like
that's his thing man weird the
stephanopoul is lean
all right well we have a little more
show us tomorrow
yes George I got a lot more to show you
tomorrow I'm going to bring you guys on
our journey through the tundra you're
going to meet all the polar bears I need
every one of these you understand me
Virgie he's doing it tomorrow very
that's an entire journey I don't care
about elections anymore I just want to
cover this I'm going to learn about the
way that we can still save the bear
which in turn is really saving ourselves
so the guns tear them off but the giant
[ __ ] v36 [ __ ] super diesel vehicle
behind you
yeah that's a good point like it's a
goddamn monster that's like that's one
of those trucks you would find a [ __ ]
at a construction site
it's all part of ABC news's ongoing
climate crisis coverage and I'm looking
forward to sharing that with you guys's
coverage what guys tomorrow but until
then watch this you guys can't do it oh
my god look no no no no no no no no no
no
come on
what are you doing he's a joke he's a
joke to them they keep him around like a
pet like it's a Mogwai like like no
seriously this is what they have that's
what they have in there for right
they're having them do wacky stuff
and they say Kanye's the guy that's like
you know
the problem let me tell you joking aside
and all that doesn't have dignity joking
aside like yeah you're right what do you
think is a better look this or what
Kanye's Kanye's really standing up for
himself right
this is [ __ ] my God it's embarrassing
that was really something can I wait for
tomorrow okay can I wait for tomorrow
hopefully those Bears [ __ ] get him
foreign
this is my new favorite bit I know man I
know Strahan's my new favorite thing
dude honestly mine too